now to something much less exciting
americans may need to start their
holiday shopping early this year because
of bottlenecks in the world supply
chains shipping containers and unloaded
ships are jamming up
ports and there is a shortage of truck
drivers to get the products out to
customers president biden is meeting
with business executives and port
directors today to try to address this
problem meanwhile our wiesha zhang is at
the white house for us covering all of
it weeja hope you started shopping early
good morning
good morning to you tony and good
morning to everybody the administration
just announced that several of the
companies president biden is meeting
with today like ups and fedex will be
moving to 24 7 operations to try to
clear up some of that congestion and two
ports in california that handle 40
percent of the country's cargo
containers will also open around the
clock but some supply chain experts
worry that still won't be enough to get
things moving
shipping delays will result in empty
shelves carly mcginnis is the ceo of a
california-based toy company struggling
to fulfill some orders because their
products are trapped in the port of long
beach mcguinness's team considered
taking drastic measures to retrieve them
chartering a helicopter to come and pie
to pull the container out of the
shipyard
we also debated renting a u-haul to
unload it ourselves thousands of
containers are stuck because the ships
transporting them have nowhere to go
it's like taking 10 lanes of freeway
traffic and squeezing them into five
ports across the country are dealing
with similar bottlenecks in march 2020
covid restrictions caused ports to cut
capacity as the economy rebounds there's
more stuff to import but on the ground
trucks can't move it fast enough due in
part to a driver shortage the biden
administration is working with states to
speed up the process to get trucking
licenses out faster ryan peterson who
runs a tech company for global logistics
says the help can't come soon enough in
any complex system where you see the
same input leading to longer and longer
delays that is a very worrying sign that
things are getting worse and worse and
worse and with less supply on the
shelves prices are surging treasury
secretary janet yellen spoke with cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
nora o'donnell is the economy unjust
when we get the pandemic under control
these pressures will mitigate and i
believe will go back to normal levels
of course one big question is how is all
of this going to impact the holiday
shopping season now some companies have
the foresight to start bringing things
in early but others that are waiting for
inventory cannot guarantee an arrival
date so ryan peterson who we just heard
from says to start shopping now nate
that's right luigi thank you